R
TENURE AS FIRST LADY AND THAT
MONEY WILL GO STRAIGHT INTO
MELANIA TRUMP'S POCKET.
A YEAR OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
AND MELANIA TRUMP IS STIRRING
CONTROVERSY.
>> MY FELLOW AMERICANS, IT HAS
BEEN THE GREATEST HONOR OF MY
LIFE TO SERVE AS FIRST LADY OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Reporter: AN HONOR THAT
APPARENTLY HAS A PRICE TAG.
MELANIA TRUMP ANNOUNCING SHE IS
AUCTIONING OFF HER WHITE HAT,
THE WIDE-BRIMMED NUMBER SHE WORE
FOR FIRST STATE VISIT DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BACK IN
APRIL OF 2018.
THE HAT MADE HEADLINES, AND NOW
MELANIA IS ATTEMPTING TO CASH
IN.
AUTOGRAPHING IT AND PUTTING IT
UP FOR AUCTION TO HER FANS ALONG
WITH A WATER COLOR OF HER
WEARING THE HAT AND A
NON-FUNGIBLE TOKEN OR NFT, A
PIECE OF DIGITAL ARTWORK OR
COLLECTIBLE, ALL FOR SALE VIA
CRYPTOCURRENCY, OPENING BID,
$250,000.
A MONEY PLAY UNHEARD OF FOR A
FIRST LADY.
>> FOR MICHELLE OBAMA TO LAURA
BUSH, NOBODY HAS SOLD ANY GOWNS
THAT THEY HAVE WORN, NOBODY HAS
SOLD PIECES OF THEIR TIME IN THE
WHITE HOUSE BECAUSE THERE IS
THIS SENSE THAT IT BELONGS TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: MOST FORMER FIRST
LADIES CATALOG IMPORTANT ITEMS
OF CLOTHING AND DONATE THEM,
EITHER TO A PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY
OR TO A MUSEUM.
SOMETHING MELANIA DID IN 2017,
WITH HER INAUGURATION GOWN,
DESIGNED BY HER STYLIST ERVE
PIERRE, GIVING IT TO THE FIRST
LADIES EXHIBIT.
PIERRE, INCIDENTALLY, ALSO THE
DESIGNER OF THE WHITE HAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN AUCTIONS OF
FORMER FIRST LADY ITEMS, BUT
THOSE HAVE TAKEN PLACE AFTER
THEY HAVE DIED.
MOST NOTABLY THE AUCTION OF
JACQUELINE KENNEDY'S POSSESSIONS
IN 1996, TWO YEARS AFTER HER
DEATH.
AND THREE DECADES AFTER HER TIME
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
ARGUABLY ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR
FIRST LADIES IN AMERICAN HISTORY
RENOWNED FOR HER STYLE, THE
AUCTION MADE THE KENNEDY ESTATE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
BUT MELANIA TRUMP IS VERY MUCH
ALIVE, LIVING IN PALM BEACH, NOT
DOING PUBLIC EVENTS, AND AS OF
LAST MONTH DABBLING IN THE WORLD
OF BITCOIN, SELLING DIGITAL
DRAWINGS OF HER EYES AND NOW
THIS.
>> FOR HER, IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN
ABOUT IMAGE, AND SHE WAS AN
ENIGMA IN THE WHITE HOUSE, AND
SO SHE'S SELLING BITS OF HERSELF
FROM A REALLY UNHAPPY TIME IN
HER LIFE.
>> Reporter: PERHAPS THE MOST
CONFOUNDING PART OF THE SALE IS
THE PERSONAL PROFIT MELANIA
TRUMP IS HOPING TO MAKE, WHILE A
SMALL PARAGRAPH AT THE BOTTOM OF
HER WEBSITE NOTES A PORTION OF
THE PROCEEDS WILL GO TO HELP
FOSTER CHILDREN, NUMEROUS
ATTEMPTS BY CNN TO GET CLARITY
FROM TRUMP'S SPOKESPERSON ON HOW
LARGE OR SMALL A PORTION AND TO
WHICH CHARITY HAVE ALL GONE
UNANSWERED.
>> NO WORDS CAN EXPRESS THE
DEPTH OF MY GRATITUDE FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF HAVING SERVED AS
YOUR FIRST LADY.
TO ALL THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY, YOU WILL BE I